Luke here at the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel I'm here with my son Tom my
nephew Ransom and we're 25 miles north
of the Arctic Circle and we're catching
massive sea fish through the ocean ice
and hunting tarmigan we're cooking up
good food and having an awesome time
[Music]
oh I feel I feel I feel I feel so unlike
all right guys welcome back to be we're
here on the shores of the Chuck Cheese
sea
[Music]
so that's the Chuck GC it's all frozen
over right now and we're gonna be here
in concert View for the next three days
you excited yeah
I'm excited we're so excited
it's about 20 degrees right now supposed
to get down around zero tonight but it
is lovely no wind but katsubu is in a
new pick Village see a lot of the signs
are in English and in yupik katsuviews
like a lot of communities here in Alaska
the only way to get here is by air
there's no roads in and out of town the
nearest Road system is over 700 miles to
the east so all the communities here are
joined by snow machine trails and get
there by boats and Bush planes
it's actually a pretty arid climate here
so they don't get a lot of snow all
these big piles of snow are from snow
drifts the wind blows frequently and it
comes in from the Chuck Cheese sea and
piles up and buries these houses okay
look at this
you guys ready
stop by the grocery store here and get
some supplies
okay oh yeah that's a proper sized
canister tank
got shelf life box Mill
all right because everything's got to be
flown in it's a little bit more
expensive here this box of cereal was
about ten dollars that thing of bacon is
29 10 for a thing of cheese Hot Dog 8 39
for a dozen eggs that's not too bad
yeah we're gonna get Cherry glazed
Fritter sorry Tom
okay what's up
this is a jalapeno cheddar burger nice
we got food for tomorrow morning and
some supplies I think it's time to go
get our fishing gear
all right I'm just gonna grab a quick
snack grab our fishing gear and we're
gonna get out and go find some fish time
to assemble the fishing gear
everybody ready
foreign
fish we're just about 100 yards offshore
from town and you can see there's just
piles and piles of sheafish guts there's
an old story about the village of
cotsaview that once it was starving to
death because they couldn't find the
caribou and the Elders of the village
made a deal with the Ravens that if they
would show them where the Caribou went
they would leave their guts out on the
ice for the Ravens to feast and so the
Ravens showed them where the Caribou
were and the people were saved and they
leave their guts out on the ice for the
Ravens to eat I see a group of ice
fishermen down there we're gonna go stop
in and see how things are going
oh looks like you're doing good there
nice fish
no it looks like the action's not super
hot but they're catching a fish here and
there
is a gorgeous Hulu knife
all those knives are gorgeous
yeah look at that nice beautiful place
yeah this is my oldest son Tommy huh hi
this is my nephew Ransom hi Ransom my
name is
care if I grabbed a chin off of one of
one of chins
baked right there yeah you could use my
order if you want to oh I would yeah I
would love that
there you go
there you go fresh sea fish chin it's
the best bait for sea fish nice and
tough too so it doesn't come off they
can't steal it from you no they won't
bring that shovel over here
[Music]
not even water well this ice is thicker
than my auger can reach looks like I
gotta go find some old holes
you're just gonna punch through these
old holes
got a little copper spoon with a piece
of Shea fish chin
here yeah
there you go reel it is
oh you got a sea fish don't grab up
there yeah
oh oh you had one Tom yeah is that
exciting Tom yeah
oh God it's a got something
it's a sculpin he liked my sheepish chin
there we go look at all the spines on
him looks like he's got little devil
horns look at that
all right bye
oh three all three barbs he wanted that
hey it's fun all the kids just got out
of school and there's all these families
and kids out fishing for sea fish on the
ice the long tradition here in kotzebue
the sea fish come in shallow in the
springtime from about the first week of
April and they're the first big food
source that becomes available in the
year so it's your first opportunity to
fill the freezer full of fresh fish
that is a nice fish look at that
check that out
that is a beautiful Alaskan cheese fish
they call them the tarpon of the North
you catch them in the summertime they
jump out of the water
look at that
he's longer than the fishing rod
these ladies over here are showing me
how it's done
that's a pile of fish yeah don't don't
fish next to these ladies if you have a
lot of pride in your ability hey guys
what's your name I'm Luke this is Tommy
foreign
yes you do
it
there you go
oh keep his head in the water yes
ah Dobby
my wrist hurts oh come here buddy you
want to get a picture with them
your first she fish what do you think is
that cool this guy's muscular why don't
you go and dump him right down there bud
right
what the heck
yeah the baby ones are big too
one thing you'll notice is that you'll
never see anyone around here ice fishing
with a fishing rod everyone uses a
little bit of antler a piece of wood and
there's a reason for that it's actually
a lot easier with these massive fish I
got a caribou antler here I'm gonna go
ahead and throw a jig on this thing and
give it to Tommy
all right
yeah
there we go
congratulations there we go another
beautiful she fish hold of your first
sea fish there stick it right up in
there don't drop him in the hole
oh huge fish and it was hard to fight
yeah
no
there we go got a little bit of sheepish
chin there
you just twist it like this and it drops
down
and when you get one just grab it with
your gloves
Lord
let's go it's good
a flounder
look at that little guy
another beautiful she fish
oh you got one
well not too bad for our first day look
at that now for the hard part gotta take
my gloves off and play them
look at all this Bait fish in his belly
that's a Tom Cod that's like a herring
another top Cod
[Music]
I got myself a cold boy and 20 30 pounds
of fillets I think it's time to call it
for today
yeah
we're a hotel freezer ain't gonna cut it
when it comes to storing our fish so let
me go ahead and bury him here over at my
friend's house
oh my goodness that's that's more than
30 pounds
all right that should keep it safe from
Ravens and dogs and stuff
all right let's go get some pizza shall
we
no problem thank you
not too bad huh it was really a nice day
but man it takes it out of you doesn't
it we're gonna just have a low-key night
here in the hotel get lots of rest
because we have a busy day tomorrow
we'll see you in the morning
well good morning sun sets around 11 30
at night and gets up somewhere around 4
30 in the morning so there is a lot of
light breakfast we've got Cherry
fritters and cereal
it's a beautiful day here in concert
Butte and it is currently four degrees
Fahrenheit outside and we better put on
sunscreen or we're going to end up
sunburned Sunburn and frostbite
oh yeah it's springtime in Alaska all
right we're all dressed up now we got to
get out of here before we overheat
this is better for now
[Music]
well guys this is the arctic tundra and
we're gonna do a little bit of hunting
we're gonna try to shoot some tarm again
which is the Alaska state bird it's a
game bird similar to a grouse or a wild
chicken that turns white in the winter
and brown in the summer and we're gonna
see if we can't find a white bird in all
of this hey Tom do you want a chance to
shoot the shotgun yeah all right come
here
it does hurt a little bit tough see that
little snow bank right there I want you
to shoot it okay pull the hammer back
and fire when ready okay
wow that did hurt that was awesome
see him there's a there's like 20 Target
right up there why don't you get the 22
ready see if we're careful about it we
can plink a couple with the 22 and then
when they take off we can shoot it with
the shotgun so just take your time and
be cool about it I mean there's no
pressure we miss it we'll get some more
you know
see watch how they're moving around yeah
there so far they're being pretty chill
okay there she they're stopping they're
starting to move away okay now you gotta
take your shot you're not gonna get much
closer than that
you're way high
there you go Tom go check it out that
right there is a tarp again turn white
the winner and they turned brown in the
summer delicious bird
look there see all the little Target
trucks those are old Target tracks right
there let's go see if we can find some
fresh ones
all right you see him
yeah let's get closer get on the snow
machine get closer
yeah I see him you see him right there
ah
Ransom you did it congratulations there
we go
my bag is gonna smell like tarm again
ah there we go
look at this just tarmigan everywhere
one two three four five at least 30 of
them right there
[Music]
so I'm learning a few things about
hunting Target they like to be around
the Willows On the Sunny Side of these
Hills but they don't want to be in the
really thick Willows that stuff's Prime
cardigan territory that stuff's too
thick oh look there's a moose right
there
there's a bunch right there they're
right there in the kind of the
moderately thick Willows
[Applause]
that'll do it
it's okay buddy
I'm really glad I gotta film that you
running and chasing I think I cracked my
elbow
uh yeah a little bit above it is like
pretty nasty right there but it is a
sharp pain I think I might have
fractured it but it still hurts tomorrow
it's probably a fracture it goes away
it's probably a bruise we are jumping
off the machines like one of the crazy
times I clipped it on something we were
chasing these tarmigan but man it's so
easy to get disoriented look at this I
think the road's that direction but
we're gonna have to follow our tracks
back to make sure luckily I got a GPS on
me but when you're chasing those birds
it's easy to get lost
very nice
there we go last bullet of the day
whoa this went better than expected but
we uh we burned up a lot of ammo we're
running low on space back here too we've
got tarmigan bungee to the back time to
pluck some tarm again and get them all
cleaned up I don't think they want us
gutting these in the hotel room there's
actually signs saying don't do that
see this one's his head his head's
turning brown turning face me
um hold your birds up
instead of white meat like a chicken no
that's the crop that's what the time
we're gonna be eating it's all twigs and
that's why you always find them by the
Willows
cutting birds in the Arctic it's a
little bit cold on the old fingers all
right I'm gonna ride with you Tom
nice chance to thaw out and wash my
hands everything smells like tarmigan uh
Macbeth
hey Branson do you want to use my knife
for your knife for the peanut butter
jelly sandwiches
mine use mine peanut butter jelly and
tarm again this is a nutritious no no
the chicken
one Ptarmigan Nutella sandwich
now that we've got some lunch in our
belly I think it's time to do some
fishing
now one thing it's important to remember
we're fishing in the ocean this is salt
water the sea fish spend the winter in
the ocean and then in the summer they go
up into the rivers and spawn and they
repeat that process each year it's a
nice nice sheet oh it has the name on it
Ransom hey Ransom is this your knife
sheath no it says Ransom on it somebody
left a knife sheath on the ice and it's
got your name on it it says Ransom
that's actually really cool I did not
bring a knife I'd say leave it there and
maybe somebody will come for it
hey a little Irish Lord look at that
oh
foreign Lord
[Music]
is that him finding me too badly
there we go
see all the wood they got stacked up
there's no trees growing around here
they have to go all the way across the
bay up there to find trees to get
firewood so people will bring in these
huge logs and then you have to chop up
all their firewood cutting and Gathering
firewood's a big deal around here it
takes a lot of time and fuel
feels nice to have not have tons of gear
on doesn't it
we got a reindeer stew here
all right good you want to try some
reindeer
you grab a little piece of that reindeer
meat it's good but I mean with the spoon
but yeah do you like it
oh that is a nice looking Burger look at
that that is a nice little Burger there
you like the mozzarella sticks
good job
he wants
well we've had a great day but I'll tell
you what my arm hurts so bad I think I
might have fractured my elbow I actually
went and called a doctor in Anchorage
about it I don't think I need to go to
the ER or anything today but
I think I might go have to go get it
checked out when I return back to
Anchorage I want to see if it's swelling
up
I can't see I gotta go look at the
mirror it's not horrible but it does
look a little gross no pain no pain no
paper we'll see tomorrow what my arm
does but it's getting late so I'm gonna
put this camera down and see if we can't
get to sleep with all this sunlight
outside
hmm good morning oh
my arm still hurts but it definitely
feels better than it did yesterday night
maybe I just bruised it and didn't
fracture it oh
we got a little snowstorm out today
I'm ready all right let's go Brave the
elements get breakfast
I love how the guys clearing the
walkways in his T-shirt
okay out
think you're out
yay
oh that's definitely me yeah
oh my
God
they've shortened the kids swing sets so
they can swing above the snow now
for those who don't know kotzebu is the
largest city here in Northwest Alaska
it's just slightly over 4 000 people
live here in concert View and also if
you want to go to some of the national
parks here in Northwest kotsubu is the
Hub you have to go to First
thank you
it got to be right there
Copic Valley National Parks and most
remote National Park in the country
right there
check it out they got an umiac boat they
put seal skin over it take it out
wailing
oh look at that kayak up there that's
cool tarvagan Snowshoe hair doll shoe
that's the Wolverine over there see sour
duck Eskimo potato and seal flipper Tom
this this city is like thousands of
years old so if you dig around in the
summertime you'll find this stuff buried
around the city this is for making the
arrow shaft straight they go and they
run it up and down when you come here in
the summertime on the beach where we
snow machine the people will set that up
and they'll dry their salmon right there
on the beach
foreign
look at that regular unleaded just under
eight bucks
now I have a boy here who really wants
to go hunting is that right Tom yes
should I do a little bit more time again
honey you can see if Tommy can't get a
bird
I think it's time to load up and do some
target practice
oh you got the back one see him
so this is where you got two of them and
then up there Tom you're doing really
good I'm actually really impressed Bud
all right let's hop on
it's got an overcast and now it's really
hard to see the Contours of the snow and
much harder to see a white tarmigan
you getting hungry Tom yeah are you cold
all right maybe go back get some lunch
okay
the guys out there are reeling in some
sea fish Tommy we might have to go catch
some sea fish after lunch
be quick go out and try to catch some
sea fish redeem ourselves from our
Ptarmigan hunt failure this morning off
we go
no that's pretty much it through it
oh there you go rad
big sea fish right there
long fish
you got an icewood
all right
you got it oh I got it I got it
oh there we go
you got one too okay that's a triple got
down fighting one oh yeah reactive over
here with one my arm needs a break
yeah see he's snagged that's why he
couldn't get him in
wow
ah that is a good one Tom ah look at
that
all right there you go
you got another one job
oh yeah there we go
diving already oh
the fishing rods are more fun but these
work so much better
you get to fish in faster you lose fewer
of them
[Music]
there we go
nice oh wow
oh they're just crazy
we've only been here about 30 minutes
and I've maybe been able to fish for a
total of three I keep having to run over
and Philip Tommy and take his fish off
the hook
pull this one out yourself this is a
great opportunity if you learn how to do
this grab the lure because it's that
it's not stretchy
you got it
hang them on the ground this guy's heavy
yeah you want to try to unhook at him
push it out push it there you go you got
him out buddy
you got one over there yeah you can
understand why I say the antlers work
way better don't they yeah I'll tell you
what guys this is arguably the best ice
fishing in North America we've been
fishing for 30 40 minutes we've got a
pile of 20 pound fish and it's just
right outside of town a beautiful spring
day it's just wonderful we've got plenty
of fish so Tom and Ranch I'm gonna go
get some Ziploc bags for me
you get it yeah I almost
there we go
oh
there we go 15 Shea fish look at that
all in about 35 40 minutes that's
ridiculous if you want to do this hole
this hole is produced almost all of them
I should really stop and clean fish now
oh nice
all right this lovely lady over here
just let me borrow her ULU knife this is
a traditional knife here
and uh it's actually an heirloom I'm
gonna go ahead and play up my first
sheet fish with the noodle knife
that was fun I think I need a lot more
practice with that
thank you so much for letting me borrow
that all right well that ULU knife was
way cooler than my filet knife but
unfortunately I'm kind of slow and my
fingers are getting numb so I think I'm
gonna fall back on what I know
if you got a sculping over there
yeah it was a skull
you got another one Dom
I kept running look at your drag just go
and get going
and you're putting those rods through
their Paces I don't know what we're
doing with this fish but I can tell you
what I'm not filleting it I think you I
hooked a seal there
really
fighter oh
look nah he's good he's in good shape
Tommy that was a rodeo
good job bud
tell you what Tom those whisker Seeker
ice fishing rods do a good job oh
look at that
oh those little orange rods are made by
whisker Seeker they're designed for
fishing for catfish through the ice but
I love them I mean they're just got
loads of strength to them
me and Ratchet are sitting here
packaging up fish and Tommy's just going
to town on s'more sea fish Catch and
Release though we're done
we have fish boxes oh it's like trying
to button up my jeans oh come on up nope
that's not happening I don't think
that's a sculpin
it must be one desperate that what
is that possible look at this beautiful
all right Tom I think we're ready to
wrap it up bud I think total we only
fished for maybe an hour and we caught
26 fish we ended up releasing a bunch
giving away a bunch what an epic day
look at this bag of fish we got
oh
streams I just
like
going will you open the door for a rest
oh man I think we got sunburned I'm a
little red oh I feel it oh I feel it on
my lips all right I'm hungry so we're
gonna go get some Chinese food almost
every major Village in Alaska has one
Chinese restaurant
people here are so friendly they just
asked Tommy if he's ever tried she fish
and he's like oh so they're like we'll
cook some up for you oh my goodness
thank you so much it tastes really good
and sea fish is a great fish
doesn't bring them back well thank you
oh those people are so nice we just sat
and chatted for a while it's like
everyone we've met here in casabia was
like that just very friendly you guys
you want to see something
see these rocks these are solid Jade see
this this is solid Jade right here
yeah
there's an entire mountain made out of
Jade not too far from here and the mine
went bust and they left some of those
Boulders there full of jade
now they use them to keep people from
cutting through the parking lot
all right we got some Mushu pork and
crab rangoon here
never had Mushu pork it's like Chinese
tacos
oh good morning it is our last day here
in kotzebue and we are eating breakfast
and packing up a healthy breakfast of
S'mores cereal I'm not gonna lie that's
good
this is
[Music]
good to see you
time to deliver some fish
those are some slams all right
you want some fish yeah let's get you
some fish make sure you have it all
right there we go there's another one
thanks Luke that disappeared quickly oh
we were eating that Lily koi Jam your
mom gave us oh my goodness well Jared
it's a pleasure man hey thanks a lot oh
well me and Becca just got rid of about
100 pounds of sheet fish and we still
have a lot left over which is a good
thing because we have some friends
coming over tomorrow and uh we're gonna
be cooking them up some tarmigan and she
fish you ready yeah well I've got a
couple recipes I'm gonna do with the she
fish and I've got a couple recipes I'm
gonna do with the tarm again the first
sheet fish recipe is I'm gonna make
smoked she fish or she fish candy it's a
recipe you might have seen me do before
two two one two
all right we let that sit overnight
foreign got all the sea fish in the
smoker we're gonna let that go for about
six to eight hours
[Music]
oh that's doing good all right time to
get the tarm again
okay one time again
six
so check it out we've got the target all
washed and cleaned you can see how dark
red the meat is now it's really normal
for wild meat the white meat you see in
domesticated chickens and pork that's
not natural that's bred that way this
red meat will have a lot more flavor and
it'll be a lot leaner so we're gonna do
is we're gonna fillet off these breasts
and we're gonna cook those separate and
then the rest of the carcass we're going
to use to make a stew
[Music]
all right we got the breast meat right
there
got some white vinegar here
the purpose of the vinegar is to draw
out the gamey flavor a little bit some
people really love that gamey flavor my
family does not I got the stockpot full
of carcasses here and I'm gonna make
stew out of this sprinkle a bit of salt
on everything Touch of this white
vinegar on there
this is tine oregano sage and rosemary
all mixed together
a little bit of ground mustard a little
bit of black pepper
we're gonna start boiling that
got that meat cooked we got to pull out
some of the meat
uh check it out right here
this is the wishbone
so each of you grab an end and you pull
it and when it breaks whoever's got the
biggest piece gets their wish the
boiling process takes all the flavor out
of the meat and so any of the good
chunks you want to pull them out at the
beginning of the process so all this
salvaged meat we want to set this aside
we're going to add it back into the stew
later on two hours later
[Music]
all right we got our tarmigan stock here
give it a little taste and see how the
seasoning is
man it's pretty bang on
first things first gonna dump in some
tomatoes
hey here we go
we got some rosemary sage and Thyme
we're just gonna bundle that up put that
right there
we're gonna add back the tarmigan meat
take a little cornstarch and water mix
it up
I don't thicken that stew up there we go
nice beautiful Ptarmigan stew back
burner this until dinner here try the
tournaments too this is oh
I'm gonna make a cranberry sauce to go
with dinner and it's really easy just
take these dried Craisins
cover them in a little water
and boiling
we're gonna pour them into a blender
now if you want to make a Thanksgiving
style cranberry sauce just reduce this
till it's the texture you want and there
you go I'm gonna make this a little
special and add some blackberries to it
just boil it until all the blackberries
mush up and turn into jelly what do you
think of this sauce
oh you look so crazy oh that's really
really good
[Music]
well I want to make sure my wife doesn't
leave me for a younger man so I'm going
to go ahead and make homemade rolls with
cheese inside to go with this meal they
are really amazing even when my looks
fade I have something to offer you
you know bread can be really complicated
or it can be really simple this is
simple bread flour yeast water
that's it all right once the yeast gets
all foamy and stuff then it's time to
add a little more water you want to add
water just a little bit at a time until
you get the right consistency
give it a good mix now we just let it
sit for about an hour and Rise all right
we're gonna knock the air out of this
okay got a little garlic powder
we'll just let these rise for another 45
minutes or until I feel like it and then
we'll throw them in the oven
oh
you got a Mickey Mouse one
[Music]
brown sugar and butter is the simplest
fish recipe but it works good on salmon
halibut whatever so delicious this is
really good to do on a barbecue
all right we're gonna make some couscous
to go with all this
all right we're just toasting the
couscous and raisins right there after
you toast the couscous just add some
water and salt couscous is looking done
all right I'm gonna pull out the cast
iron skillet here
we got garlic tine Rosemary and Sage
we're just gonna put that in the butter
right there
there we go
pecorino Romano cheese
we got some smoked lake trout here I'm
gonna take the skin off
all right
[Applause]
there we go smoke late trout carbonara
hey guys welcome what's up hey
eventually yeah
oh all right here I want this piece try
a bit you guys ever you guys know what a
sea fish is
big white fish that lives up above the
Arctic Circle tastes really good yeah I
come on
well guys I forgot that we've signed up
to feed the volunteer missionaries from
our church and it's good you can because
we ended up having a lot more food than
we expected so uh have you ever guys
ever had she fish before nope no ever
had cardigan before nope nope you're
gonna take a lot of boxes today uh we
got some basil couscous we got biscuits
with cheese in it we've got a tarmigan
stew
um and put a little cilantro on there we
got the tarmigan breasts and we've got
this cranberry blackberry sauce it goes
with the breast and then we have a
smoked lake trout carbonara over there
which all right oh pepper
what do you guys what do you guys think
about the uh tarmigan tastes almost like
deer yeah yeah it'd be tastes much more
like deer and stuff like that very lean
the real test is whether Becca likes it
I don't usually like wild meat wild meat
weirds are out
but she really likes blackberries I love
this sauce the vinegar really helped
tone down the gamey flavor those little
rolls are so good
[Music]
who
right here let me hand you that and I
will swap you
there you go you guys full
we took it no yes yeah good sea fish it
looks good you want to eat a good fish
it's a really good fish you know she
fish is a nice white meat it's not as
flaky as halibut but it's kind of like
cod you know I think maybe a little bit
so guys thanks for coming by appreciate
it that was fun but I am so full that
was a lot of food hopefully you guys
enjoyed this video if you guys want to
see more fishing camping and adventure
videos from the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel don't forget to click subscribe
we put out new videos every Saturday
morning all right guys we'll see you
next Saturday if you like this video
don't forget to check out the outdoor
Boys YouTube channel where we have
hundreds of videos just like this and
don't forget to click subscribe so you
can see other great videos every
Saturday morning and hit that Bell
button you'll get notifications thanks
for watching